- I feel like this is ElimiDate.
Like, we just added a guy now,
and I got moved to the side.
- [Kelly] Well then I
feel like I'm gonna lose!
(all laughing)
Definitely with that competition.
Um, we worked together though,
on The Crazy Ones.
- Yes, we did.
- Okay, so the last
time we saw each other,
I was like kind of dancing awkwardly
and inappropriately on you in a scene.
So, it's nice to just see you casually.
- It is so good to see you.
- Yes!
- You were so awesome on the show.
- [Kelly] You were very nice.
I hate acting.
The only reason why I said yes
was 'cause all y'all in it,
and I was like, wait, I
can't pass this up. (laughs)
- No, you did a great job.
- [Kelly] You're very nice.
But, I love you, though.
On that show, you were selling products.
I remember, it was the pilot,
and I found out what the
whole show is about, and
you were selling products.
But, you actually did that
in life, before acting.
- Yeah, exactly.
On the show, the show
was about an ad agency,
and we were selling that
product, and we pitched you,
that was really, that was fun.
And in real life, I grew up working
at my dad's shoe store,
women's shoe store.
I said it like that
because, usually, you know,
women like shoes.
- You got a foot fetish?
(everyone laughing)
- I think Chrissy
is on ElimiDate.
- I don't know...
- Don't look at mine, though!
- I don't, I hate when
people touch my toes.
I'm like, get away from my toes!
Anyway --
- I think I'm similar with that.
- [Kelly] Yeah, I don't like
people touching my toes.
- Yeah, I wasn't like, a toe toucher.
I just sold the shoes.
(everyone laughs)
And, I would you know,
say, "These look great".
And I was like 14, it was my dad's store.
- All right, so do you still
get the employee discount?
Like, for your wife?
- My wife does.
Our closet is basically her shoes,
and then I have, like, two T-shirts.
(Chrissy laughs)
She gets some pretty sweet shoes.
- Yeah, 'cause shoes are
awesome, they always fit.
- [James] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- Yeah (laughs)
- They always fit,
unless you have children
and your feet grow, huh huh huh.
Anyway.
(everyone laughs)
- Oh my God, I'm going
through that right now.
- Oh my gosh, I had to
get rid of all my shoes.
- This poor dude is sandwiched by us.
(everyone laughing)
- I could talk about shoes--
I love shoes, I could
talk about shoes all day.
- Wait, can I ask you a
question about Watchmen?
I'm sorry Kelly. (laughing)
- I thought you were
gonna say about shoes.
- No, I told her to
ask you cause she said,
"Wait, so with Watchmen..."
and she had something
to ask you so I said well ask
him when he gets out here.
- No, cause it was a viral thing.
People were talking about someone sliding
through the gutter.
I was wondering if it was CGI or if it was
an actual stuntman.
Can you tell us now, if someone sliding
through this tiny gutter--
- Like Slenderman, he went
right through the thing.
- Yes, exactly.
He was running and then
mask gone, everything--
- He poured the stuff and he slid through.
and then slid through the gutter.
- By the way, without context--
- I just got so
claustrophobic, like Oh my God
I would never do that.
- Yeah, without context the
show sounds totally wild.
- Yes.
I love that we just attack your guest--
- But I'm in, I love it.
I'm sorry.
- That's great, and he
was wearing great shoes
(Kelly and audience laughs)
he was wearing great shoes--
- Amazing shoes.
- Slippery ones.
- I think there was a lot of CGI in that.
(Chrissy inhales)
- Wait, that's good to know.
- I think there's an amazing--
- [Kelly] Well done.
- Well, because I'm
about to try it tomorrow
so I just wanted to know.
(everyone laughs)
- Don't wear those shoes.
- She's about to re-enact it.
Well let's talk about the Watchmen,
what's it about?
- Watchmen is about, it's
based on a graphic novel,
and basically being a
superhero is outlawed.
They're basically vigilantes.
- I am so in.
- And it's really dark.
And Damon Lindelof is
the creator of our show,
which is on HBO.
And he took that idea and
he took the graphic novel
and this now is set like
30 years after the original
graphic novels set in a
dystopian, kind of like,
alternate universe,
United States of America.
And it's nine episodes
and it's a wild ride.
It's really fun.
- But they're still like
trying to help people?
Is that the thing, is that what happens?
- That's right.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- The show opens up and there
is a murder that takes place.
- Oh, it's like Clue?
- Yeah, and we spend--
it's like Clue, yeah exactly.
(everyone laughs)
- Do you like Clue?
- I love Clue.
- You love Clue.
- Kelly, we have to stop
creeping out our guest.
- I literally just
played Golden Girls Clue
the other night with my--
- Golden Girls Clue?
That's a thing?
- Cause somebody got it for me and my son
was like, "I wanna play
Clue" and we couldn't
find the original. (laughing)
- So you found the Golden Girls?
- Yes, it was awesome, I was Dorothy.
(everyone laughs)
- [Chrissy] That is the worst Clue.
- Anyway, let's actually
talk about your show.
- [James] That's awesome.
- So they do though,
the super heroes still
wanna help but they
don't wanna get caught.
- Yeah, so basically
super heroes are outlawed.
And then the police, it takes
place in Tulsa, Oklahoma,
and the police in Tulsa,
Oklahoma are all masked.
And so it deals a lot with
the idea of wearing a mask
and what that means.
This event takes place and you basically
spend nine episodes in
this world, figuring out
what happened, and it's--
- That's exciting.
- [Chrissy] So good.
- really fun.
- What a cool job.
- Yeah, it was an amazing
experience filming
the show and shooting it.
- [Kelly] Yeah, all right.
- We didn't play Golden Girls
Monopoly between scenes.
- See, you missed out.
You missed out, you should have.
(Kelly and Chrissy laughing)
- [James] I wanna play that.
- I couldn't find the original.
- Wait, so are you dying to
do a rom-com or something now?
- Right, after such a--
- [Kelly] You would be great in a rom-com.
- Yes, I agree.
- Oh my God, thank you.
Well we did, the show that
we did together was comedy.
- Yeah, but I just mean like a movie.
Like I feel like rom-coms kinda died.
I loved Crazy, Rich Asians.
- Well, can I bring the rom to your com?
- Yes.
(everyone laughing)
- Y'all should do it.
Do it.
(Chrissy laughing)
- It took me a second by
the way, I just started
nodding and then I said yes.
- [Chrissy] You agreed to
it on national television.
- [Kelly] It is contractual.
- I'm gonna just keep
scooting outta this frame.
- No, it's great, it's great.
- We have to take a break,
we'll figure out this movie
while that's happening.